bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 sur
tvfils 78 en direct entre 18 et 19h en
ce 19 novembre nous allons faire le
point sur l'actualité et l'actualité du
jour les élections au sein de l'UMP le
chaos c'est la une du monde en ce début
d'après-midi nous allons forcément
parler avec nos invités dans les
prochaines minutes vous allez le voir
avec le sommaire en images dans le
département la situation est tout de
même moins agitée qu'au national à l'UMP
le duel a été remporté par François
Fillon dans les Yvelines avec 59,2% des
voix l'ancien Premier ministre était
soutenu par Valérie Pécresse présidente
départementale de la formation nous
commanderons ces résultats notamment
avec l'ancien député des Yvelines
Jean-Michel fourgousse mère d'Élancourt
un nouveau maire pour la ville de
plaisir sans surprise jeudi soir lors du
conseil municipal extraordinaire
l'ancien adjointe à la culture Joséphine
colemanz Berger a été élu elle siégée
auprès de Joël Réunion depuis 2001 elle
est l'invité du 7 8 ce soir vous
l'entendrez dans un instant une salle de
relaxation pour les malades d'Alzheimer
et les patients atteints de troubles
physique cela se passe au centre
gérontologique de Chevreuse un
dispositif entièrement financé par des
fonds privés là aussi ils nous en
parlerons en plateau avec nos invités et
puis elle s'apprête à rejoindre l'île
Maurice pour participer au Raid Amazon
du 25 novembre 3 décembre elles se sont
53 franciliennes et parmi elles
plusieurs 5 continents et puisque l'on
parle de sport Anthony Reich bonsoir la
chronique sport du lundi il en sera
aussi question de ce rêve d'Amazon oui
autour de cette table deux invités
Nathalie Gauthier Isabelle Rinaldi deux
participantes du raid qui sont en train
de préparer leurs valises justement pour
pour ce red de l'Arbre Vert direction
l'île Maurice elles seront avec nous sur
ce plateau pour nous donner leur
dernière impressions avant le décollage
qui aura lieu dimanche nous parlerons
aussi de football féminin l'as Montigny
qui est reconnu pour pour sa formation a
reçu il y a quelques jours le label
d'école de football féminin nous
essaierons d'en expliquer les raisons de
ce succès et puis comme d'habitude tous
les résultats du week-end à la chronique
que sport du lundi à suivre dans une
vingtaine de minutes les salariés
d'Alcatel Lucens sur le site de Vélizy
toujours mobilisé ce matin ils ont
défilé dans les de la ville à l'appel
d'une inter syndicale avant qu'une
délégation ne soit reçu par le maire de
la ville Joël Loison et il dénonce les
1430 suppression de postes en France
ainsi que la fermeture du site de
Vélizy-Villacoublay à la semaine
dernière le directeur général délégué du
groupe spécialisé en télécommunication
ainsi que le directeur du comité de
groupe France et le DRH d'Alcatel Lucens
en France était sur place à la rencontre
des salariés pour expliquer ses choix
les salariés dénoncent les erreurs
passées et surtout un manque de
stratégie au-delà du plan social pour
les prochaines années on passe donc au
fait du jour et il concerne l'UMP ce
soir
bonsoir tout d'abord à Joséphine
Coleman's berger merci d'être venu sur
ce plateau vous êtes depuis jeudi soir
la nouvelle mer de cette ville de
plaisir on va en parler tout à l'heure
et puis bonsoir à Jean-Michel fourgousse
maire d'Élancourt UMP ancien député de
la 11e circonscription des Yvelines
votre formation politique l'UMP se
déchire depuis presque 24 heures
François Fillon Jean-François Copé
revendique tous les deux la présidente
de votre partie il s'accuse de fraude et
tout ça en direct devant les caméras au
micro des radios à travers toute la
France même la presse étrangère s'y
intéresse quel est votre sentiment à
chacun Michel fourgousse
du monde des États-Unis en 2000 entre
algor et bouche souvenez-vous ça s'est
tranché en Floride pour 300 voix c'était
extrêmement tendu ça durait un mois bon
en 2008 souvenez vous le Parti
socialiste enfin les mots échanger entre
Madame Royal et madame Martin
variété entre nos amis socialistes
c'était c'était beaucoup plus violent
que ce que j'ai entendu entre monsieur
Copé ou Monsieur Fillon bon maintenant
vous empêcherez pas c'est très tendu
pourquoi c'est très tendu parce qu'il
est évident que quelque part et grâce à
Monsieur Hollande
qui perd la confiance tous les jours des
français bien sûr qu'il y a une attente
des Français très forte sur la personne
qui va sortir de ce scrutin parce
qu'elle a de fortes chances on va pas se
le cacher d'être président de la
République donc il est évident que
l'attente est-elle et puis le scrutin
est très très et très court entre les
deux et très étroit donc bien sûr que il
y a une tension des deux équipes mais il
y a pas eu une ni de bourpif ni
d'échange ou de la violence qu'on a pu
voir en 2008
hier soir on dirait sur les différentes
chaînes d'informations
de votre point de vue comment vous avez
suivi cette soirée électorale et encore
les échanges qui ont lieu aujourd'hui
comment j'ai
oui c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
regrettable qu'on puisse voir que il y
ait toute cette tension mais l'attention
elle vient aussi beaucoup des médias
vous savez bien autour d'une élection
comme celle-là comment ça se passe les
médias qui inventent les propos et puis
les politiques savent très bien servir
des médias pour faire passer le message
aussi les propos sont là mais ça dépend
aussi comment on les amène sur un écran
vous le savez très bien c'est très bien
qu'on peut être spécialiste du découpage
mais je vous accompagne tout à fait il
faut être tout à fait légitime il est
vrai que il y a des tensions et c'est
des tensions dû effectivement
oppositionnement également qui attend
ces deux personnalités là
ce qui est peut-être regrettable c'est
que cette élection se termine par une
forme de déchirement comme c'était comme
tu le disais très justement aux parties
socialistes on aurait aimé pouvoir ne
pas avoir cette problématique là mais
c'est une question du jour vous savez
très bien et puis quand la personne sera
élue et bien on essaiera d'oublier tout
cela et puis on avancera d'un comme un
accord puisque je sais que profondément
ces deux hommes se respectent alors bien
évidemment on peut attendre les
résultats vous l'avez dit pour autant il
y a deux camps qui réclament la
présidence de l'UMP c'est ça aussi qui a
pu surprendre ne serait-ce que les
adhérents de l'UMP on verra tout à
l'heure et puis parce qu'on pense la
population de se déchirement de l'UMP le
monde qui titrait le chaos cet
après-midi il y a des termes très forts
qui sont employés pour qualifier cette
fin de campagne et ce se déroule de
scrutin c'est une situation surprenante
au-delà de ça il y a un enseignement
François Fillon qui était annoncé comme
vainqueur véritablement que vous avez
soutenu d'ailleurs durant cette campagne
même s'il était lu ce sera un score très
très serré et la surprise elle est aussi
là c'est que Jean-François Copé s'est
fait entendre et s'est fait entendre
auprès des militants moi je me félicite
parce que dans une situation grave vous
savez que la France va vivre un moment
très dur il faut pas se le cacher en
2013 du fait de sa situation avec
l'argent public on le sait ça va être
très ça va être ça non très dur
peut-être très grave kevinant que nous
on a deux candidats qui sont très bons
Fillon est très bon il a 5 ans
d'expérience Premier ministre il a été
très bon copain était plusieurs
féministe il est très bon aussi je
dirais que maintenant ces places à
l'unité bon ils ont fait leur campagne
chacun voilà ça va être étranché avec
les 20 derniers départements et puis
voilà mais
oui il y en a un qui est peut-être
un petit peu plus
libérale l'autre qui est enceinte du
social non mais c'est vrai mais cela dit
c'est le socio c'est le système
socio-libéral en Europe en France donc
je dirais c'est les et les deux
tendances sont en ça vous verrez ils
dirigeront ensemble et vous voudrez il y
aura une répartition c'est déjà prévu
d'ailleurs on le sait bon donc voilà
simplement le vrai problème c'est que on
a besoin de quelqu'un d'expérimenter
c'est le cas de ces deux personnes de
compétences que quelqu'un qui prend des
décisions et vide parce qu'aujourd'hui
devant la situation il faut aller vite
ce qui est pas le cas de Monsieur Lang
il faut il faut décider bien or il ne
comprend pas l'économie et il faut
décider fort il faut arrêter les mesures
et qu'il faut des mesures fortes voilà
ce qu'il faut pour sauver le pays je
peux vous dire que les deux hommes dont
vous parlez Fillon Copé ils sont
compétents pour faire ça et c'est ça qui
nous rassure nous à l'UMP et qui nous
ration pour demain on va juste écouter
regardez pardon une phrase la phrase du
jour de cette édition elle est signée
Valérie Pécresse député UMP des Yvelines
qui ont quatre victoires de François
Fillon pourrait aussi devenir secrétaire
général du mouvement au niveau national
voici cette phrase on publie les
résultats et après on les conteste l'UMP
doit respecter le droit électoral on
parle de fraude on parle d'erreur ne
serait-ce que 128 bulletins litigieux
c'était encore en fin d'après-midi du
côté de Nice par exemple Jean-Michel
fourgousse dans votre commune on a voté
dans votre mairie on a voté les
militants sont venus comment s'est passé
le scrutin comment s'est organisé le
scrutin aussi autre bien écoutez nous on
n'a pas eu de contestations mais c'est
vrai que il y avait un seul bureau de
vote bon pour la circonscription c'est
vrai qu'on l'a vu dans certaines villes
aussi où il y a eu 4000 personnes sur un
seul bureau
justement le manque de bureau de vote
organisément mais de la dire que c'est
le chaos que c'est Beyrouth non alors je
sais que
mon éminent de collègues le dit très
bien bon journaliste c'est normal vous
faites vous êtes dans votre chacun son
rôle bon on a compris
qui sera là pour donner d'autres
solutions à la France qui pour pour
freiner enfin pour pour résoudre
l'essentiel des problèmes des Français
qui sont le chômage je peux vous dire
qu'on va vers plus de 500 000 chômeurs à
mon avis en 2013 on va vers un
assèchement du crédit pour une
entreprise on va vers une augmentation
du dépôt de bilan c'est très grave donc
il faut des compétences économiques il
faut aller vite très vite pour sauver
des centaines de milliers d'emplois et
je vais moi il y participer que ce soit
monsieur Copé que ce soit monsieur
Fillon on sera tous avec eux voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire donc il faut
l'unité donc il faut la laisser
tranquille unité il va falloir tout de
même qui est le président
en tout cas l'opinion publique de cette
situation voici un micro-trottoir signé
et le dis-moi
que je sais pas c'est ça
je trouve ça on va dire pour l'image de
d'un parti comme l'UMP ça va que ça va
faire exploser le parti finalement c'est
n'importe quoi
je pense que ça fait
ça fait un peu
mais on n'a pas choisi les gens non plus
pour avoir la place honnêtement ça a
l'air d'être un sacré bordel on verra
les résultats mais pour l'instant je
j'ai pas entendu les infos mais je crois
qu'il y a rien eu de toujours de définir
donc ça ça donne un pas très très bon
exemple je trouve
alors vous parlez tout à l'heure des
médias c'est vrai qu'il y a eu beaucoup
d'échanges via les médias il y a aussi
des échanges via les réseaux sociaux et
là les médias n'y sont pour rien et via
les réseaux sociaux on apprend aussi
qu'il y a beaucoup d'adhérents à l'UMP
qui déchire leur carte et qui pensent
partir vers d'autres formations
politiques alors en fonction de leurs
affinités plutôt vers le Front national
plutôt vers l'UDA et également ça vous
inquiète pour l'avenir chacun ou pas de
voir les militants partir il y a aussi
des échéances bientôt vous l'avez dit
faut se mettre en ordre de marche
rapidement les municipales c'est 2014
c'est finalement assez proche je sais
qu'il est à la mode dans ce pays de
survaloriser le micro exemple moi je
n'ai pas qui m'ont dit je quitte l'UMP
mais enfin ça ça voilà donc pas
d'exagérer
dans le monde allez allez voir un peu
dans les pays où il y a pas de
démocratie alors c'est vrai que vous les
voyez pas se disputer sur un plateau
mais alors allez voir derrière les coups
de poignard les bons donc attention les
démocratie quelquefois regardez je crois
il y a des pays comme ça c'est toujours
le bordel mais c'est la démocratie et on
n'a pas trouvé
meilleur système que la mes photos
lyrique
on peut être en et puis il y a une
extension
en ce moment l'enjeu est tel que bien
sûr qu'il y a une petite tension mais de
grâce c'est rien ça dans un mois je te
demande il est reparti tout droit et
tout le monde est derrière celui qui
sera choisi selon bien sûr le résultat
électoral vous partagez cet avis c'est
pas une implosion du MP il faut pas
exagérer on est effectivement dans dans
dans une un moment d'historicité je veux
dire au niveau de la politique bon c'est
vrai c'est un passage c'est un passage
qui peut paraître compliqué mais il faut
quand même penser aux centaines de
milliers de de d'adhérents et qui sont à
l'UMP et qui sont tout en confiance je
vous le disais tout à l'heure il y a un
grand respect malgré tout vous savez
bien que les campagnes sont des moments
très très fortes très appuyé on est
passionné il faut respecter ça c'est
aussi ça comme disait Jean-Michel la
démocratie c'est ça c'est la passion
mais je peux vous dire que l'UMP est
bien là elle est bien présente les
adhérents sont là moi j'ai pu les
croiser sur le terrain au niveau de
plaisir hier
comment voulez-vous comment
vous que ils ne le soit pas parce que
tout ce qu'on peut entendre aujourd'hui
dans les médias bien évidemment moi-même
je peux pas être content de tout ce
qu'on peut entendre d'excessifs mais
c'est l'excessif du moment prenons le
moment tel qu'il est là sachant que
demain nous aurons je l'espère
rapidement les résultats et derrière on
sera on sera là bien présent et je peux
vous dire que l'UMP ne va pas souffrir
de ce passage là vous croyez que le
Parti socialiste visiblement a souffert
de ce qui s'est passé lors de l'élection
donc par les monsieur fourgousse
regardez Monsieur Hollande a été élu ou
bien grave
mais aujourd'hui président de la
République tout à fait mais je veux dire
ça n'a pas détruit une partie socialiste
que je regrette d'ailleurs
mais je vais vous dire l'UMP est bien là
et on sera là pour être vigilant pour
tout ce qui évoquer monsieur fourgouse
sur les difficultés aujourd'hui de
l'État et il va falloir vraiment qu'on y
pense résultat au niveau national des
résultats en revanche dans le
département des Yvelines je le disais
tout à l'heure 59, 2% pour François
Fillon on va voir quelques tableaux
s'afficher avec différents scores le
meilleur score de Jean-François Copé se
trouve dans la huitième circonscription
c'est la seule circonscription et les
réussit à s'imposer 58,4% à noter que
Jean-François Copé qui était soutenu par
Henri Guaino dans la troisième
circonscription ne fait que 41,6 % et
dans la dixième celle de Jean-Frédéric
Poisson il ne fait également que
41,6% pour revenir sur cette journée de
dimanche mais aussi sur le dernier
meeting de campagne de Jean-François
Copé à samedi soir dans les Yvelines je
vous propose de suivre ce reportage il
est signé Valérie Auribeau et Anthony
Rech
contrairement à la division qui fait
rage au niveau national l'élection à la
présidence de l'UMP dans les Yvelines
n'a pas fait l'objet de discussion elle
a été remportée par François Fillon l'ex
Premier ministre remporte plus de 59%
des suffrages pour 40 % de vote pour
Jean-François Copé sur 10793 inscrits
6361 votants se sont déplacés jusqu'aux
urnes une bonne participation qui veut
dire que c'est une campagne qui a bien
intéressé nous militants et
qu'aujourd'hui à l'UMP on a une démarche
citoyenne et les militants ont été votés
François Fillon remporte la victoire sur
la plupart des circonscriptions sur la
première circonscription François Fillon
obtient 62% des votes contre 37%
seulement pour Jean-François Copé 71%
sur la deuxième contre 28% pour
Jean-François Copé sans la troisième 58%
pour François Fillon 41% pour
Jean-François Copé pourtant soutenu par
Henri Guaino député de cette
circonscription sur la dixième fief de
Jean-Frédéric Poisson soutient également
de Jean-François Copé l'ex Premier
ministre enregistre 58% des voix contre
41% pour le maire de Meaux sur la 11e
François Fillon obtient 56 % contre 43 %
pour Jean-François Copé enfin sur la 12e
le score est de 55 % pour François
Fillon contre 44% pour Jean-François
Copé les deux hommes étaient venus ces
derniers jours dans le département pour
s'exprimer auprès des militants à
commencer par François Fillon à Poissy
mardi 13 novembre entouré de ses
soutiens
il n'est plus là pour satisfaire son ego
plus du tout il me l'a voulu même
et donc on a besoin de ça pour conduire
l'UMP et la droite et pour rassembler au
plus large regagner dans les urnes
avec François Fillon c'est possible
parce que c'est le seul qui peut à la
fois être suffisamment ferme pour nous
ramener les électeurs qui sont partis au
front national et en même temps
suffisamment républicain ouvert serein
pour nous ramener les électeurs
centrices qui sont partis voter Hollande
samedi dernier Jean-François Copé était
quant à lui à Saint-Germain-en-Laye le
maire de Meaux avait souhaité rencontrer
les yvelinesois pour son dernier meeting
le département où il a grandi un
département qui ne lui aura pas pour tes
chances mais samedi soir Jean-François
Copé et ses soutiens avaient prévenus
pas de division à l'issue des votes que
l'objectif il nous faudra naturellement
nous rassembler je les dis si je suis
élu dans l'heure qui suit j'appellerai
François Fillon et tous ceux qui ne
l'ont pas soutenu pour une famille
politique rassemblée pour l'avenir je
suis sûr que j'en peux soit coupé et
François Fillon feront tout pour que tu
marches mais vraiment sincèrement
l'homme de la situation aujourd'hui
continue la France que nous sommes dans
l'opposition l'homme de la situation
c'est Jean-François
dimanche le bureau de vote d'Élancourt a
vu les militants se déplacer en nombre
pour exprimer leur choix parfois avec
une file d'attente de plus d'une heure
un choix pas si tranché que ça pour tous
les deux sont
ils sont peut-être un petit peu
différents mais je pense que l'un comme
l'autre ont des grandes valeurs pour
défendre la force le vote au niveau
national est pour leur toujours
incertain mais les militants yvelinois
eux ont bel et bien tranchées
et toujours pas de nous si vous nous
suivez en direct entre 18 et 19h on va
juste libérer rapidement Jean-Michel
fourgouse pour s'intéresser aussi à
votre élection Joséphine Goldman smerger
en tant que maire de plaisir Jean-Michel
fourcrousse une dernière question ça
concerne la participation à ce scrutin
58,9 % dans l'ensemble du département
c'est un chiffre satisfaisant oui une
tension interne c'est satisfaisant
d'autant plus avec les critères très
très difficiles parce que quelqu'un qui
venait juste derrière il pouvait pas
donc du coup on a perdu peut-être 8% de
nos électeurs si on aurait fait les deux
tirs je crois qu'on aurait fait 65 66 %
madame Pécresse Valérie Pécresse a été
bien sûr il patronne du département on
le retrouve dans bien sûr dans le vote
du département et c'est normal et c'est
aussi bon signe pour elle donc tout va
bien l'UMP c'est
ce soir
merci Jean-Michel fauc vous êtes revenu
sur le plateau juste je vous donne deux
informations et vous allez voir qu'une
surprise en chasse une autre François
Fillon était donné vainqueur sur cette
élection il fouchait lui était donné
vainqueur pendant la campagne pour la
présidence de la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des Yvelines il s'est
incliné jeudi dernier lors du scrutin
face à Plaisir roi Gérard bachelier
gérant Dao concept c'est ce dernier qui
a été élu avec 19 voix contre 18 il
prendra ses fonctions le 1er janvier 201